[Music]
here sorry I'm late
it uh I'm sorry I'm late mmm I'm in the
studio today doing some final tweaks to
my album I have to go to Vegas tomorrow
where I'm not only celebrating my
birthday with the family I'm also
performing at the Soul Train Awards
getting this incredible legendary award
I am excited but a little overwhelmed
but I'm really excited this weekend
before that we set it off to mastering I
want to finalize some of the mixes okay
I'm here Hardaway the clean version
clean version does not exist okay let's
hear the raunchy version what does B say
he says hos and the N word says the N
word for sure I don't know about hos he
definitely said hos this song contains a
lot of curse words which is not common
for a Toni Braxton song so the label
wants to know how much cursing is on the
track in case they want to release it as
a single they're not sure yet will it
make the album so we'll see
had a few browser holes that I like
ain't like no I'm shooting for the stars
I know I'm buying all the cars five star
be the dawn okay some of those were I
don't know what some of that stuff means
I don't know what half of that means
something worth more than money it's
done of man go to church free to
birdsall son it's that feat of free
Legos also wants to them they want to
know if his birds or freedom or freedom
can we feed him or do we freedom go to
church free the birds on Sundays free
free the birds a free could mean free to
let him go where you feed it I mean you
feed it let's feed it and you oh you
feed that fed them and you're saying
freed let me ask tomorrow she would know
she tell like my Ebonics specialist I
don't know rap words what it means all
the time I didn't know what surfboard
meant for the longest time would be
honest they said that and I found out
but I didn't know it first hey Tay oh no
no I just got a question to ask you on B
song Hardaway he he says I got something
worth more than money go to church read
the birds on Sunday what's that mean she
talked about I'm a bird
oh my god like after you get married
where's the bird like for real
are you sure freed the birds on Sundays
nobody gets married on Sundays okay bye
thank you for coming out god bless you
good night good night
I understand thicker better I didn't get
so sweet it's a love song
[Music]
[Applause]